at least 50 people have been killed more
than 300 others injured after two trains
collided in India's eastern addiction
State India's Prime Minister Modi says
the Collision is a grave accident that
saw a passenger train derail and collide
with a good strain now rescue operations
as you can see are underway at the site
we're hearing that the coromandel
express which runs from Kolkata to
Chennai derailed and then fell onto the
opposite track leaving many people still
trapped that's according to local media
reports these are some of the first
pictures we have from the scene and as
you can see a huge Collision as a
passenger train comes into the tracks of
a good strain both colliding there 50
people known to have died
300 have been hospitalized or Sky's
Neville Lazarus joins me now on the line
from New Delhi just looking at these
pictures Neville this is a huge tragedy
that's correct Jonathan the there were
three trains involved in this crash uh
10 to 12 coaches derailed of the
coromandel express sent on to the
adjoining track which was then rammed by
another passenger train and three four
quarters three or four quarters of that
train derail fell on another track and
the freight train then hit it and as you
can see the pictures uh these are mangle
remains of of the train of all the of
the two passenger trains and also the
freight train uh we believe there are
doctors that have died uh the
confirmation of the numbers will come
much later but there are at least six to
seven hundred people according to
reports and officials saying that who
are involved in the rescue operation
some from the national disaster relief
force with uh with Cutters uh they're
trying to rescue some of the passengers
from from the from entangled and mangled
sort of remains of these coaches or
hospitals of balasore District have been
put on high alert the injured have been
carried by almost 50 or 60
ambulances that have that have gathered
around these around the signs of the
crash taking the injured to hospitals
a large number of police Personnel fire
brigade fire engines about 50 of them
out there and the operations are still
going on it will take uh quite a long
time to get to get this cleared and to
know what's the actual damage and and
the death numbers all the injured that
have that have happened in this terrible
tragedy